(audience applauding)
Yeah, all right, yeah, all right, yeah.
I feel the enthusiasm right of the top, yeah.
We are, yeah, New York, New York, New York.
(audience applauding)
That's, that's where we at.
New York, yeah, New York.
Yeah, everywhere, yeah.
You got to keep your hands in your pocket
in New Yorks, yes, ya'll are busier around here, man.
A lotta, lotta walkin', lotta walkin',
and I like it 'cause y'all got a lot of good crosswalks,
the countdown crosswalks, yeah,
I like those things right there.
Let me know how long I got
to get across the street, yeah.
'Cause I wasn't raised on the countdowns.
I just had the man and the hand,
and ah, yeah.
audience laughs)
'Cause you don't know, you don't know when
the man or the hand gonna come up,
you just out there taking a chance
with the man and the hand.
(audience laughs)
Like man, that hand came up fast as hell right there.
Let me, let me get on out the street
But here, you see the countdown, let ya know.
Like I look up sometime and like man,
I got 34 more seconds!
(audience laughs)
You know, I can,
I can walk back and forthin 34 seconds, man.
Say "Why you still in the street?"
'Cause I got time!
(laughter)
That's why I'm still in the street.
But yeah, man, but that's a beautiful and diversity, man.
That's what we gotta have, but diversity,
I like it 'casue it's diverse, yeah.
Don't let the noise get to us.
Don't, don't, yeah, don't, don't, don't, don't,
don't build no wall.
Build a bridge to somebody, yeah.
(audience cheers loudly)
Yeah, let somebody...
Yeah, let's, let's bring the people in, man.
'Cause I know we under new management as a yeah,
we under new management.
It's like your favorite restaurant, and you went to,
ike man, them people don't own this store no more?
So ah. (wheeze)
Yeah, so that's what we did in a way,
"You know like this, this don't taste like it used
(audience laughs)
"to when other people had it."
That's all it is, is a different flavor.
THat's all it is, 'cause you know,
there's different seasoning, that's all
that's going on with the whole Trump movement,
it's just different seasoning.
I knew he was going wrong, 'cause it's all about seasoning,
what you put in your food and ah, like in the cabinet.
I was watching the cabinet selection.
He started off wrong with the seasoning,
(laughter)
'cause...
Yeah, 'cause I come to your house and look at your cabinet,
that let me know, you know, how you gonna,
what kinda flavor you're putting in your greens.
I need to know.
And I was watching the selection, I was like man,
that's a, that's a lotta salt right there.
(uproarious laughter)
That's a lotta salt.
Yeah, that's a lot of,
(energetic applausr)
lot of, lot of salt.
I said, you can't, you can't make any good greens
with all that salt right there,
we gonna have high blood pressure right there.
(audience laughs)
And people say, "Oh, what about Ben Carson,
"that's a different seasoning."
I say naw, that's accent right there, that's just accent.
That's not black pepper, that's substitute salt.
(audience laughs and applauds)
(wheezes)
(ovation)
Take your time, take your time, take your time.
So yeah, man, I just, you know I say go,
you know, go be around other people.
Go to different places sometime where you may not go.
Don't just stay in your neighborhood.
Go see what other people are doing.
Like I go to the city sometime, and I just pop up in places.
Like I like to go through the mall sometimes
just to see what people are doing at the mall.
What they, you know, selling at their little kioskses,
and that's a new word right there, Kiosk.
(audience giggles)
You know, nobody was raised
on the word kiosk, that just
came out of nowhere right there.
Yeah, 'cause I didn't call them kiosks,
I used to call them little stands,
what's what I thought they was.
People say, "Where you get that from?"
"That little stand over there,
(laughter)
that's where I bought that"
Yeah, I've never said "at the kiosk over there", but ah.
I'm a big fan of the food court at the mall,
'cause I like samples.
I love a, yeah, a sample.
If you got something on a toothpick,
I need to know what the hell going on, on that toothpick.
I love the Asian people, I love the Asians,
'cause y'all always have a sample an it's, and it's yeah,
it's always a shiny piece of meat,
(laughter)
it's always just...
Just so shiny!
Man, I said, man.
And they, "Sample, sample?"
Yes, I would like a piece of that shiny meat, who don't.
I can't turn down no shiny meat.
And I understand what a sample is.
That's just, you know, that's just a suggestive sale.
They're saying "if you like this shiny meat,
there's more shiny meat to purchase.
(laughter)
And sometime I get
the taste in my mouth, I say,
"Man, I think I want some more shiny meat."
And they're so nice, I go over
and order it from the counter, and she says,
"Sir, would you like rice to chow mein in the,"
I always go with the rice 'cause I still
really don't know what chow mein is.
(laughter)
Yeah, I don't know who the chow or the mein, I don't know.
I wasn't raised on that kind of spaghetti.
(laughter)
Yeah, I said, don't put them peas in there,
I don't want them peas.
Yeah, I don't really eat baby carrots in my spaghetti.
But ah, yeah, but beautiful, beautiful people,
and they're look, so you just gotta get
to know people every once in a while.
And they, I get the rice and they're so nice with the rice.
Yeah, the lady just kept giving me rice.
Just giving me rice.
And I said "Ma'am, I just want some rice for today."
(laughter)
Yeah, I said, "I don't have that much shiny meat
for all this rice right here."
So that's, yeah, I had a lotta,
I had like a 60 pound bag of rice!
I said, "I gotta find
a little small village to drop this rice on."
I been right, man, man,
I appreciate the love and enthusiasm here.
(ovation)
Much love, man, thank you very much, thank you!